Now it's time to see the single corner model of a car in action.
The program test different strengths of braking
so that we can learn about the equilibria that we've analyzed before.
The mass of 1/4 of the car and the effective mass of the wheel are provided
20 kg for that effective mass of the wheel is a little on the high side,
but helps to make the simulation more stable.
Your first task is to fill in the initial values.
You want to start with the car speed of 120 km/h and no slip, perfect rolling.
The other task for you is to implement the forward Euler method.
We make sure that the wheel slip never decreases below zero.
This helps to make things more stable.
Your task is to compute x which is the position, V which is the velocity of the car,
and W which is the velocity of the rim of the wheel and then we're cleaning up a little
to make sure that the velocity of the rim of the wheel is never negative.
Again, we measure to make things more stable.